well luckily there's not a fire it's
this deadly circling the globe right now
you can treat seizures
no no she came back from a trip and she
was drug MDMA ecstasy no no we don't do
that when you went through this movie in
the process of joining so much time
focusing in on germs and what could
happen and all that did you change your
everyday interactions how did you change
your dealings with everyday interaction
really you know I I'm pretty fast and
loose with my germs I mean I think we
yeah you know no I appreciate the
immunities you know what I mean I and I
want my kids to have them too but but
you know we live in New York City so we
wash our hands every time we get home
and and we're and I'm much better about
that now having done contagion you know
but still it's just kind of the nature
of human beings and if you live in a
city or you know we're all on top of
each other even if you don't your kids
are going to collapse to gether and
stuff gets passed around it kind of is
what it is
you know I in New York I don't have an
earthquake kit next to my bed in New
York and obviously and there was
actually an earthquake there recently so
so I I don't know I mean I I like to
think that my wife and I have thought of
you know a lot of eventualities but it
look it's always things that you don't
expect that kind of blindside you and
and can kind of expose how unprepared
you are for stuff so we have a novel
virus with a mortality rate in the low
20s no treatment protocol and no vaccine
at this time this portrays a very
different side of humanity what I think
you know when there is a virus that's
this contagious and this deadly I think
that people do get a little bit of every
man for himself
survivalist instinct and I think it does
you know bring out the worst in a lot of
ways and you see that but then you know
ultimately it's about hope at the end of
the film well I shouldn't give it away
but at the end of the film you see some
very hopeful moments and you know you
see the beauty of the human spirit and
the
the generosity of the human spirit as
well the average person touches their
face two or three thousand times a day
two or three thousand times a day three
to five times every waking minute you
can't avoid it I mean making contagion
you know when you're when you're
involved in something where this is the
subject matter you know how easily germs
are spread and how mysteriously and
easily a virus can start and spread very
quickly yes of course you know I'm much
more obsessive now about taking shoes on
and off and hand-washing and and not
touching handles in and out of public
restrooms etc I think you can get a
little obsessive but I also think it's
no bad thing to be aware
[Music]